it's not an original accusation but
let's restate it nevertheless we didn't
ask to be born you were were cast from
the blissful piece of nothingness into a
world of exam rejection compromise and
pain no wonder if we push rather a lot
of our complaints your way it is in the
deep sense or your fault but take it as
a tribute to you if we do complain you
have to feel pretty safe around someone
before you dare to tell them you hate
them we overestimate you how could we
not given how tiny and helpless we were
when you were already huge and skill
adult unfortunately when you
overestimate people you can also resent
them a lot when you start to discover
the humdrum reality we encountered you
before we have any capacity deal with
your quirks in maturities your bad taste
in music we were helpless before you we
have to blame you for being in some ways
mad like your parents were and theirs
before them you react too strongly
your emphasis on weird places your fears
are excessive your tics peculiar you
forget how far you grow up the helpless
two-year-old we once were isn't
necessarily our true self
it's just the version of us you find
easiest to admire that's kind of an
insult of its own you love us perhaps
but with what complicated specific and
sometimes oppressive ideas of what we
should be like don't blame us for
finding fault with you we have to find
your habit irritating if we admired you
too much we wouldn't have any input
to grow up and get on with our lives
though of course try as we might to get
away from you we'll never quite be able
however mediocre you might be you will
always seem a bit supernatural to us
you